Herzlich Willkommen beim Rasenfunk und das hier ist nicht die Schlusskonferenz. Ich bin der Max und bei mir ist der Frank. Hi Frank.
Hi Max.
Frank, weil das nicht die Schlusskonferenz ist, muss es logischerweise eine andere und ganz neue Sendung sein. Und jetzt wird es spannend, wie heißt denn die neue Sendung?
Tribünengespräch.
Und um was wird es in den Tribünengesprächen gehen?
Um wechselnde Themen. Wir werden uns mit einem oder mehreren Gästen zusammensetzen, wahlweise entweder nur einer von uns oder wir beide, und werden über ein Thema sprechen, das wir für besprechenswert halten rund um den Fußball.
Genau. Und der Unterschied zur Schlusskonferenz wird ganz einfach sein, dass wir uns nicht nur auf den letzten Spieltag beziehen, sondern es geht um generelle, allgemeine Themen.
Genau, so ist es. Da werden dann auch Themen dabei sein, wie zum Beispiel, wenn es um eine Trainereinlassung geht, um einen aktuellen Transfer, der irgendwie für Aufruhr sorgt, der eine Diskussionsgrundlage bietet. Oder eben auch mal ein Thema, das völlig losgelöst von der Aktualität ist und einfach generell Diskussionsstoff bietet. Und wo wir natürlich auch das Gefühl haben, dass wir jemanden kriegen können, der darüber uns Auskunft geben kann. Und wo wir vor allem für die Hörer dann eine gute Basis sehen für Informationen und für ein Gespräch.
Genau, wir freuen uns da schon sehr drauf auf dieses neue Format. Wir hoffen, dass es euch auch gefällt. Es wäre toll, wenn ihr den neuen Feed, den ihr hiermit dann auch mitgeteilt bekommt, bitte abonniert. Wann geht's los, Frank?
Frankfrage, ja. Wobei, das können wir relativ gut sagen, in den nächsten Tagen. Weniger von dem Tag, an dem wir die Aufnahme hier machen, als von dem Tag, an dem wir sie dann tatsächlich veröffentlichen. Also ihr könnt in den nächsten Tagen schon mit der ersten Ausgabe rechnen. Worum es da gehen wird, wissen wir noch nicht. Aber das wird bestimmt ein tolles Thema sein.
Davon gehe ich aus. Und um nichts zu verpassen, likete uns am besten bei Facebook, folgt uns bei Twitter, kreist uns ein bei Google Plus oder folgt uns bei app.net. Ihr alle beiden, die ihr da noch aktiv seid. Wir freuen uns auf euch.
Ihr müsst auf jeden Fall nur das Zeichen vorne dran austauschen. Add Hashtag plus irgendein Satzzeichen neben Rasenfunk dahinter schreiben. Dann seid ihr richtig.
Genau. Und weiter freuen wir uns nicht nur über viele Feed-Abonnenten, sondern auch über positive Rezensionen. Jetzt vielleicht nicht direkt zu dieser Nullnummer. Das wäre noch ein bisschen verfrüht, denke ich. Aber ihr könnt gerne die Schlusskonferenz bei iTunes net bewerten. Das hilft uns, ein bisschen bekannter zu werden. In diesem Sinne sage ich danke, Frank, für deine Zeit. Ganz toll, dass du hier auf unserer Tribüne Platz genommen hast, wo du doch so viel mit anderen Podcasts beschäftigt bist.
Jederzeit wieder.
Und danke an alle Hörer, die sich das jetzt schon mal angehört haben. Ihr könnt euch geehrt fühlen, ihr wart von Anfang an mit dabei, als etwas ganz Großes entstanden ist. Und wir freuen uns bald wieder von euch zu hören.